this place is cold it's wet and it's
filthy
at a glance it's just a collection of
sodden tents but each one is a home for
the thousands who live here look
carefully and a community is revealed
streets shops churches schools
everything to make their lives feel a
little more normal
the school has two classrooms one for
the teenagers and adults it's full
everyday and another for the toddlers
again always busy it was built by zamak
Oh from Nigeria he now faces the
prospect of seeing it all bulldozed next
door was shown through the maze by staff
from Save the Children a charity which
never imagined its work would be needed
in France gives them a sense of
community they come here at the end
don't English they can borrow books in
the library and it's an absolutely vital
part of life life here I think that no
one's saying that
the jungle should remain as it is people
shouldn't be living in these conditions
and particularly children but until
you've got alternative solutions in
place for children don't do what's here
because you're risking pushing them into
other camps and in France when worst
conditions all other places over the
past month the authorities have already
cleared this section here creating a
buffer zone a sort of no-man's land
between the camp on this side and the
highway here where the trucks head
towards the port itself the plan now is
to do the same with this whole southern
half of the camp to clear away all these
tents the question though is where the
people go the answer say the authorities
is here a collection of purpose-built
shipping containers but there aren't
nearly enough of them to house the 3,000
or more who would be displaced and there
is no school no church and no mosque
here in the shadows of the containers is
the home of a family from Sudan father
nadir invites us inside to see his
five-year-old daughter muhuali
she's ill with a fever and he is quite
clearly
broken man lay around a Theodore I'm
saying I'm so pain fall inside emotional
pain and got pain inside me because of
her the family fled Sudan after their 19
year old daughter was kidnapped by
militiamen they've been living like this
for seven months there are stories like
this right across the camp among those
here though are a proportion whose
attempt to board the trucks to the UK a
violent the police are stretched that's
why the authorities say the camp must go
but remove the only community these
people have and it's possible the
desperation and the violence will only
get worse mark stone Sky News in France